you uh and your lovely wife Nia have a
one-year-old son uh daughter
one-year-old daughter
no it's all right it's all right it's
all right what are you supposed to
memorize what everybody has no I have
one guy whose job it is to tell me if
it's the son of a daughter and he's
right there oh it's squirming behind me
uh yeah pretty much you said I had a son
I thought we were friends yeah
wow yeah anyway not that I really rely
on these things but it's just no bill uh
we have a one-year-old daughter yes I'm
just curious
I said take two no take two I don't know
we're gonna keep all that in I want
people at home to know just how shitty
things are around here